let's go today to our caller from the
707 area code who is calling today from
7:07 yes my name is Gabe I'm calling
from Humboldt County hey Gabe what's up
okay sorry making sure you can hear me I
can hear um yeah so I'll be real brief I
really appreciate you taking me on I
live in a rural part of California and
one of our major crops here is marijuana
yes I'll take in fact i-i've year I was
up there once for a conference and I the
conference was in Loya it was near
youkai data Arcada
exactly I was up and all that in
Mendocino yes and yes my own County yeah
we have country it was crazy yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah well I live a more rural
part of California and I'll try to be I
got a try be brief of my questions so
first of all Joe Biden does not have a
pro legalization stance now my father
was a grower I'm a second-generation
American and my family still deals with
immigration issues so on that I am
extremely anti-trump but on that I'm
also an type iDEN because he not only
doesn't support the main cash crop from
my county but he also was in power when
I've had family members being deported
so I'm moreso wondering why I should
vote for Biden in terms of what's the
difference because to me I'm looking at
it like you got red version and blue
version of the same person and by voting
for Biden I'm not only continuing my own
family's destruction but my country's
destruction because it's a one-party
system right well let me ask you I'm
curious if there's any answer sorry go
ahead let me ask you this if we think
about the future of marijuana
legalization which we're seeing a lot of
at the state level right so a lot of
what we're seeing the next five to seven
years of marijuana legalization will
come from the state level not from the
federal level is my prediction do you
believe that we will get more favorable
rulings of cases that our appeal
to the Supreme Court related to cannabis
if Trump picks a replacement for Ruth
Bader Ginsburg or if Biden picks a
replacement for Ruth Bader Ginsburg what
does your heart tell you on that okay so
I'm actually really glad you asked me
this I thought about this a couple days
ago I was talking about wife about this
so Trump and the Republican Party are
pro money and right now in Humboldt
County there is huge massive
multi-million dollar corporations coming
here and spending money there lobbying I
think that marijuana legalization even
with a trump in office is closer than
you think
now again I will never vote for a
right-wing death cult I'm not going to
vote for Trump the Republican Party you
know they want to see of my state burn
to the ground and so on that and I just
want to tell everyone here do not vote
for Donald Trump don't do it but on that
same level it's like the difference
between the left and the right and this
one is minimal because it's like okay
yeah you may get someone who may not be
favorable towards it but financially
they'll let it go I mean it's just like
you know alcohol prohibition you know
I'm sure a lot of that let me sleep just
a little bit here because you're saying
a lot let me I so I I don't know I I
think there's no doubt I think okay so
hold on I think there's no doubt that
whoever Biden picks to the Supreme
Supreme Court would be better on this
issue
then whoever Trump picks I also believe
oh no doubt I also believe that remember
back during the obama-biden era they
said even though weed is illegal
federally we're not going to send
federal agencies into states that have
legalized it when Trump put in Jeff
Sessions it but they did though Obama
administration there was many raids by
the feds during those times there is no
doubt that there were but they were
dramatically diminished whereas Trump's
AG ran on we're gonna ramp that back up
so right for me
it is it is not my best Walker you
believe that nothing Gabe thank you for
the call
I very much appreciate it and I hope
that you you know make the decision that
is right for you let's take a quick
break don't hang up if you're holding
because we will be right back with your
calls in a brief moment